Hallo, guten Tag. Ich heiße Dr. Mustafa Aydın. Ich bin hier auf der Station als Assistent tätig und möchte mit Ihnen dieses Gespräch führen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, bin ich.
Ja. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Petra Schneider.
Petra Schneider. Frau Schneider, könnten Sie Ihren Nach- und Vornamen langsam buchstabieren?
Ja, der Vorname Petra. P-E-T-R-A. Dann Schneider. S-C-H-N-E-I-D-E-R. Schneider.
Danke schön. Sehr gut. Und wie alt sind Sie, Frau Schneider?
Ich bin 48 Jahre alt.
48. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 24. November 1977.
24. November 1977.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,69 Meter.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
66 Kilo.
Okay. Ich möchte wiederholen. Sie sind am 24. November 1977 geboren.
Ja.
Okay, danke. Und was fühlt Sie zu uns, Frau Schneider?
Ja, ich habe seit zwei Tagen Fieber und Schüttelfrost. Und ich bin müde und schlapp.
Und ich habe auch etwas Luftnot beim Treppensteigen. Sobald ich mich etwas anstrengen, habe ich Luftnot.
Ja, und ich habe Schmerzen im Rücken so unterhalb des Schulterblattes. Rechts am Rücken habe ich Schmerzen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seit zwei Tagen Fieber haben, oder?
Ja.
Seit zwei Tagen. Okay. Sie haben gleichzeitig auch Schmerzen in den Rücken und zwischen dem Schulterblatt.
Ja, mehr auf der rechten Seite, unterhalb der Schulter. Also etwas tiefer als die Schulter. Da tut es am meisten weh.
Auf der selben Seite. Hatten Sie schon früher Anlegerbeschwerden?
Nein.
Okay. Wie sind Schmerzen? Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Luftnot beim Treppensteigen haben.
Ja, also seit wann?
Ja, auch seit zwei Tagen, seitdem ich das Fieber habe.
Okay.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Nein, Brustschmerzen nicht. Aber ich habe Husten.
Und Husten? Husten Sie trocken oder mit dem Auswurf?
Nein, ich habe Schleim. Schleim ist das.
Und haben Sie eine Farbeveränderung im Auswurf gemerkt? Zum Beispiel rote oder braun?
Es ist ein bisschen bräunlich, braun.
Okay. Gibt es jemanden, der eine Anlegerbeschwerden hat?
Nein.
Okay. Sie haben gesagt, Luftnot beim Treppensteigen und Schmerzen im Rücken.
Haben Sie Schmerzen beim Einatmen?
Etwas, aber nicht so stark. Es ist mehr so ein Dauerschmerz im Rücken.
Dauerschmerz. Haben Sie Fieber gemessen?
Ja.
Was war die Haut?
39,2.
39,2. Was haben Sie dagegen gemacht?
Bis jetzt noch nicht. Ich komme jetzt zu Ihnen, damit Sie das untersuchen.
Ja, es tut mir leid, dass Sie solche Beschwerden haben, aber machen Sie keine Sorge.
Und wir werden diese Ursache finden.
Okay.
Und Frau Schneider? Schmerzen, haben Sie gesagt.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine gemerkt?
Nein. Ich habe keine geschwollene Beine.
Haben Sie andere Beschwerden, die gleichzeitig aufgetreten sind?
Ja, ich schwitze sehr stark und habe Schüttelfrost, das habe ich ja schon gesagt.
Und Husten habe ich eben.
Dann habe ich bemerkt, dass mein Wasserlassen auch nicht so gut ist.
Ich habe manchmal Brennen beim Wasserlassen und der Urin riecht ziemlich stark.
Normalerweise riecht mein Urin nicht so.
Riecht stark. Aber trinken Sie ausserhalb des Wassers?
Ja, das glaube ich schon.
Okay. Brennen.
Aber seit wann haben Sie Brennenschmerzen beim Wasserlassen? Wer merkt?
Ja, auch so seit zwei Tagen jetzt.
Seit zweieinhalb. Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Jetzt nicht gut. Mit dem Fieber ist er nicht gut.
Okay. Und dann könnten Sie schlafen? Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise kann ich ganz gut schlafen. Aber seitdem ich jetzt das Fieber habe,
auf die letzte Nacht war nicht so gut. Da habe ich so stark geschwitzt.
Und das fand ich so gut.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab- oder zugenommen?
Ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Okay, sehr gut. Und dann?
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit erkältet?
Erkältung? Nein. Erkältung hatte ich nicht.
Ich möchte zusammenfassen. Seit zwei Tagen haben Sie Fieber,
Sterfrost und Luftnot beim Treppensteigen und Schmerzen in den Rücken.
Auf der rechten Seite Schultblätter und Husten mit Schleim und Braunliche.
Und ja, Sie haben auch Schwitzen und brennende Schmerzen beim Wasserlassen.
Und Ihre Ohren riechen sehr stark.
Wie ist Ihr Urinfarbe?
Also trüb. Mehr trüb. Nicht so klar wie sonst.
Haben Sie Schmerzen beim Geschlechtsverkehr?
Kann ich nicht sagen. Hab ich seitdem nicht gehabt.
Okay. Und dann? Müssten Sie häufig zur Toilette gehen?
Ja, Wasser lassen. Ein bisschen häufiger als sonst.
Häufiger als sonst.
Wie ist die Urinmenge?
Kann ich nicht sagen. Hab ich nicht beobachtet.
Ich verstehe. Und dann? Haben Sie irgendwelche Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe erhöhte Cholesterinwerte. Blutfette und Cholesterin sind erhöht.
Dann habe ich eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse.
Da sind zwei Knoten auf der rechten Seite. Das muss auch immer kontrolliert werden.
Das habe ich auch jetzt seit einigen Jahren schon. Bestimmt schon 10 Jahre.
Und dann habe ich auch Gallensteine. Das ist vor zwei Jahren entdeckt worden.
Da hatte ich eine Gallenblasenentzündung.
Und man hat mir geraten, ich soll das operieren lassen.
Aber das habe ich bisher nicht gemacht. Ich möchte mich nicht so gerne operieren lassen.
Aber das muss ein bisschen unangenehm sein, oder?
Ja, ich weiß ja nicht, ob das jetzt alles von der Gallenblase kommt.
Die Beschwerden. Vielleicht hängt es damit zusammen. Ich weiß es nicht.
Also ich habe die Gallensteine noch. Und wie gesagt, die Ärzte möchten gerne, dass das operiert wird.
Aber ich möchte noch abwarten.
Haben Sie Duschweil?
Nein.
Wie sieht Ihr Stuhl aus?
Dünner oder hell?
Da ist mir nichts aufgefallen.
Und dann? Haben Sie andere Vorerkrankungen? Bluthochdruck?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Und wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als Kind. Da war ich 10 Jahre alt. Da wurde ich an den Manteln operiert.
Und als ich 30 Jahre alt war, da hatte ich einen Sturz auf der Treppe.
Und da habe ich mir den linken Unterschenkel gebrochen.
Beide Unterschenkelknochen. Also Badenbein und Schienenbein musste operiert werden.
Und vor einem Jahr wurde meine Gebärmutter entfernt.
Warum?
Weil ich viele Myome hatte.
Und das war schon ziemlich ausgeprägt. Und dann hat man die Gebärmutter entfernt. Das war vor einem Jahr.
Und dann andere Operation?
Sonst nichts.
Das war genug, oder? Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, für die Schilddrüse nehme ich ein. Wollen Sie wissen, wie das heißt?
Was heißt?
Troxin?
Nein, Eutyrox.
Eutyrox. Eine morgens.
Wie viel Mikrogramm?
Da steht 50.
50. Okay. Einmal morgens.
Und dann nehme ich noch zum Senken von Cholesterin.
Ectimib heißt das. Ectimib.
Ectimib. Sollte ich das buchstabieren?
Ja.
Das schreibt sich E, dann Z, I, T, I, M, I, B. Ectimib.
Ectimib.
Ja, da nehme ich eine Tablette morgens von. Dahinter steht 10. Das ist, glaube ich, die Stärke.
Dann nehme ich zusätzlich noch Rosovastatin.
Rosovastatin.
Ja, das nehme ich auch noch. Eine morgens. Dahinter steht 20.
20 Milligrand morgen.
Und andere?
Nein, sonst nichts.
Okay. Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergie bekannt?
Nein, Allergien habe ich nicht.
Unverträglichkeit? Haben Sie Unverträglichkeit?
Nein.
Okay. Frau Schneider, sind Sie in den Wechselnjahren, oder?
Nein, noch nicht. Meine Periode ist noch regelmäßig.
Regelmäßig. Besuchen Sie Ihren Frauenarzt?
Ja, einmal pro Jahr.
Rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauche. 10 Zigaretten pro Tag. So seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren. Okay. Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so am Wochenende mal ein Glas Wein, zwei Glas Wein. Also maximal zwei Glas Wein pro Woche.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich. Konsumieren Sie irgendwelche Drogen?
Nein.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und lebe mit meinem Mann zusammen.
Aber Sie haben Kinder?
Zwei Kinder. Eine Tochter, 18 Jahre alt.
Gesunder?
Ja, ein Sohn, der ist 16 Jahre alt. Die sind beide gesund.
Okay. Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Ja, der Vater ist 79 Jahre alt. Der hat hohen Blutdruck.
Und eine Herzklappe ist nicht in Ordnung. Das ist diese Herzklappe.
Hat er mir erklärt.
Eine Herzklappe. Die schließt nicht richtig.
Ja, kann man sagen.
Ihr Vater hat Herzklappe. Das funktioniert nicht gut.
Deswegen ist es nicht gut.
Also das ist die Herzklappe. Hat er mir erklärt.
Die aus der Herzkammer in die Hauptflachader geht.
Ja.
Die Herzklappe. Und die schließt nicht richtig.
Kann man sagen Herzklappe insuffizient?
Ich kenne das Wort nicht.
Also die schließt nicht richtig.
Okay, braucht er eine Palästheule?
Malerweise schließt sie sich wohl immer gut.
Aber die schließt sich nicht richtig.
Und das belastet sein Herz.
Und muss ja immer kontrolliert werden.
Aber im Augenblick wird das immer nur kontrolliert.
Und er nimmt auch Medikamente ein. Aber ich kenne die nicht.
Kann ich nicht sagen.
Ja, und dann meine Mutter. Die ist auch 79 Jahre alt.
Die hatte vor 5 Jahren Darmkrebs.
Vor 5 Jahren wurde sie operiert.
Und bekam auch noch anschließend Chemotherapie.
Aber bisher sind die Untersuchungen gut verlaufen.
Sehr gut.
Und sie hat auch noch Alterszucker.
Alterszucker.
Alterszucker, ja.
Also erst vor 10, 15 Jahren ist der entdeckt worden.
Dann habe ich noch eine Schwester.
Die ist 47 Jahre alt.
Die hatte vor einem Jahr eine Gallenblasenoperation.
Wie alt ist sie?
47.
Gallenblasenoperation.
Ja.
Und dann.
Frau Schneider.
Ich wollte ein paar noch Fragen stellen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie...
... wussten und mit dem Ausruf haben.
Ja.
Bei ihr wurde schon mal eine Sinusitis festgestellt.
Was ist eine Sinusitis?
Sinusitis, das heißt Entzündung der...
... Entzündung der Gesichtknochen.
Ja.
Nein, das habe ich auch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Und dann...
Haben Sie keine Übelkeit, keine Erbrochen?
Nein, Übelkeit und Erbrechen habe ich nicht.
Aber eben wenig Appetit.
Das hängt mit dem Fieber zusammen, glaube ich.
Ja, gibt es einen Auslöser für Ihre Beschwerden?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Erinnern Sie daran?
Oder was verbessert oder verschlechtert Ihre Beschwerden?
Also ich kann mich schlecht anstrengen.
Körperlich ist schlecht.
Weil dann bekomme ich schnell Luftnot.
Ich bin ziemlich müde von dem Fieber und Schlapp.
Also ich behalte mich lieber ruhig.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Waren Sie schon mal ohnmachtig?
Nein.
Okay, Frau Schneider.
Ich, ja.
Haben Sie noch andere Fragen?
Ja, ich frage mich natürlich, was kann das sein?
Weil sowas habe ich ja noch nie gehabt.
Aber Sie werden das denke ich jetzt feststellen durch Untersuchungen.
Ja.
Frau Schneider.
Ich vermute, dass Sie eine Entzündung in der Lunge haben.
Und dann, ja.
Aber ich würde gerne eine Urinuntersuchung durchführen.
Und auch ob Sie gleichzeitig eine Urininfektion haben oder nicht.
Und dann möchte ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und Blut abnehmen.
Damit wir im Blut sehen können, ob Sie eine Entzündung haben oder nicht.
Okay, das können wir so machen.
Und auch möchte ich durchführen.
Ja, prima. Dann können wir das so machen.
Dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit, sich vorzubereiten wieder für unser Gespräch.
Was war der Fall?
Ja, Sie müssen sich vorbereiten.
Sie müssen jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, was heißt Appetitlosigkeit auf der Fachsprache.
Diese ganzen Dinge.
Dass Sie sich das vielleicht etwas zurechtlegen.
Die Medikamente nochmal.
Die Operationen. Was wurde operiert?
Wie ist die Diagnose der Schilddrüse? Sowas.
Gibt es von den Kollegen und Kolleginnen noch Ergänzungsfragen?
Ja, wo genau haben Sie Fieber gemessen? Eine wichtige Frage.
Ich sehe das unten. Ja, ich habe das im Mund gemessen.
Die Frau hat das im Mund gemessen.
Sie können die Frage aber ruhig auch so stellen, indem Sie das sprechen.
Aber Sie können das auch in diesem Chat schreiben.
Ich würde schon noch so zwei Fragen stellen.
Die Periode regelmäßig? Ja, noch ist die Periode regelmäßig.
Die Gebärmutterentfernung war ja vor einem Jahr.
Also bis dahin war die Periode regelmäßig eine gute Bemerkung.
Also Fragen würde ich noch stellen zum Schmerz.
Ich habe Rückenschmerzen.
Ich würde noch fragen, können Sie den Schmerz beschreiben?
Die Schmerzkarte.
Verstärkt sich der Schmerz? Wird er weniger?
Ist er dauerhaft? Das haben Sie etwas gefragt.
Wichtig ist noch der Schmerzgrad.
Wie stark ist der Schmerz auf der VHS-Skala?
Wenn Sie das fragen, sagt die Patientin, zwischen 5 und 6 ist der Schmerz.
Eher 5. Was könnte man noch fragen?
Eine Patientin, die Fieber hat.
Haben Sie etwas dagegen eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe bisher nichts dagegen eingenommen.
Kein fiebersenkendes Mittel.
Ich würde die Frage der Reiseanamnese noch stellen.
Ich wollte diese Frage stellen, aber ja.
Ja, Sie wollten sie stellen.
Wenn Sie fragen, haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Fernreise gemacht?
Wenn Sie aus dem Ausland waren, würde die Patientin sagen,
im Februar war ich für zwei Wochen in Tunesien.
Sagt die Patientin. Im Februar.
Also jetzt vor acht Wochen war sie in Tunesien.
Da ging es mir aber gut.
Tunesien.
Da war alles in Ordnung.
Darf ich fragen?
Haben Sie jemanden in Ihrer Umgebung mit ähnlichen Beschwerden?
Nein, das hat der Kollege auch schon gefragt.
Ob es jemanden noch im Umfeld gibt.
Nein, ich kenne keinen.
Die sind alle gesund.
Meine Familie ist gesund und auf der Arbeit auch nicht.
Ich arbeite übrigens als Sekretärin bei einem Steuerberater.
Das ist mein Beruf.
Hab ich vergessen.
Würden Sie eine Covid-19-Impfung durchgeführt?
Habe ich im November gemacht.
Im letzten November wurde eine Covid-Impfung gemacht.
Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerden?
Nein, das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Danke schön.
Wenn keine Fragen kommen, lasse ich Sie einige Minuten in Ruhe.
Die Rückenschmerzen strahlen irgendwo aus.
Kommen Sie zu sich?
Zum Beispiel in dem Krankenhaus.
Die Patienten fragen uns, wo ich meine Temperatur gemessen habe.
Wie können wir diese Antwort für die Patienten erklären?
Wenn der Patient sagt, ich habe Fieber, würde ich fragen,
wann und wo Sie gemessen haben.
Dann sagt der Patient entweder im Ohr oder am Afterektal.
Am schlechtesten ist Axilla.
Das ist sehr ungenau.
Dann sagt die Patientin im Mund.
Dann notieren Sie sich auf Ihren Bogen oral gemessen.
Dann fragen Sie, wie hoch das Fieber ist.
Warum fragen Sie diese Fragen?
Es ist wichtig zu wissen, wo man das Fieber misst.
Es gibt Unterschiede in der Körpertemperatur.
Wenn Sie in der Achselhöhle messen,
dann ist die Temperatur etwas ungenauer.
Man muss wissen, wo Sie gemessen haben.
Wenn jemand sagt, ich habe unter der Achselhöhle gemessen,
dann kann man davon ausgehen,
dass die Temperatur noch etwas höher ist.
Sie sollten fragen, wo Sie gemessen haben.
Es gibt heute viele Methoden, Fieber zu messen.
Sie wissen das vielleicht aus der Sache von Covid.
Dann gibt es Detektoren am Flughäfen.
Die messen ihr Fieber auf 2-3 m Entfernung über eine Sonde.
Da gibt es schon sehr technische Möglichkeiten.
Ich lasse Sie jetzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen.
Darf ich machen?
Es handelt sich um Frau Petra Schneider.
Sie ist 48 Jahre alt.
Sie ist am 24. November 1977 geboren.
Sie hat eine sehr starke Arthrose.
Sie ist 1,69 m groß und wiegt 66 kg.
Die Patientin stellte sich heute wegen
der bestehenden Müdigkeit, Fieber und Luftnot
beim Treppensteigen vor.
Sie könnten sagen,
die Patientin stellte sich wegen
seit zwei Tagen bestehender febriler Temperaturen
Fatigue und Dyspnoe beim Treppensteigen
oder bei körperlicher Belastung vor.
Da hätten Sie noch ein paar Fachbegriffe.
Ich kann hier anfangen.
Wie hoch ist die febrilische Temperatur?
Die Patientin sagte,
dass die Temperatur 39,2°C beträgt.
Wo gemessen?
Ich habe das schon gehört.
Durch den Mund.
Oral.
Gut, danke.
Fahren Sie bitte fort.
Die Patientin sagte an,
dass sie gleichzeitig Schmerzen in der Rücken,
besonders auf der rechten Seite, haben.
Sie klagte über Krust mit Auswurf.
Die Farbe des Auswurfes ist braun.
Sie hat braunliche Auswurf.
Und dann Begleitsymptom.
Sie klagte über Schwitzen, Schüttefrost.
In der vegetarischen Anamnese gab es an.
Die Syrie.
Und der Geruch im Wind.
In der Appetanz und insomnia.
Jetzt versuchen wir noch mal danke.
Sie haben das sehr gut aufgelistet.
Aber für meine Briefe zu wenig medizinische Ausdrücke.
Sie berichtet über einen Schmerz im Rücken.
Über einen rechtsdorsalen Schmerz.
Dorsal rechts.
Ohne Fortleitung.
Das wurde auch noch mal gefragt.
Sie berichtet über Tussis.
Und mit bräunlichem Expectoranz.
Tussis war bräunlichem Expoxter.
Auswurf oder Sekret.
Bräunlichem Auswurf.
Dann haben wir Tussis da drin.
Sie berichtet über Schwitzen.
Da sagen Sie vielleicht Hyperhidrosis.
Das wäre noch wichtig.
Die Dysurie haben Sie bemerkt.
Sie beobachtete einen Fötiten.
Oder einen unangenehmen Fötor.
Im Urin.
Der Urin riecht Fötide.
Fötide ist kein angenehmer Geruch.
Das ist ein unangenehmer Geruch.
Das Urin riecht nicht gut.
Das merken Patienten, wenn der Urin seinen Geruch verändert.
Sie hat eine Dysurie.
Und der Urin ist Fötide.
Sie hat gesagt, die Urinfarbe ist etwas trüb.
Trübe.
Nicht klar.
Was hat die Patientin sonst noch berichtet?
Das sind die Akutsymptome.
Ist die Patientin sonst gesund?
Hat sie chronische Erkrankungen?
Normalerweise sind die Patienten gesund.
Was hat sie für chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja.
Chronische Erkrankungen sind Hypercholestronomie.
Hypotreude und Cholestitis bekannt.
Die Patientin hat gesagt, sie hat eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse.
Sie hat nicht gesagt, sie hat eine Überfunktion.
Oder Unterfunktion.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse.
Kennen Sie den Begriff?
Ja, Stroma.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat zwei Knoten.
Wie würden Sie die Diagnose sagen?
Eine Stroma nodosa.
Das wäre die medizinische Diagnose.
Wir wissen nicht, ob es eine Hyperthyreose ist oder eine Hypotreude.
Sie nimmt ja auch ein Medikament.
Ja, die Patientin hat gesagt, sie hat gesagt,
sie hat gesagt, sie hat gesagt,
sie hat gesagt, sie hat gesagt, sie hat gesagt,
sie hat gesagt, sie hat gesagt, sie hat gesagt, sie hat gesagt,
Gut, sie nimmt Eutirox. Welche Dosierung? 50 Mikrogramm. 50 Mikrogramm, einem pro Tag, morgens.
Was nimmt denn die Patientin sonst noch ein? Sie sagen, sie hat eine Hyperkolesterminämie und Hyperlipidämie. Was nimmt sie da?
Dagegen nehmen sie Ezytimib und Rosopastatin, 20 Milligramm morgens.
Ja, und Ezytimib, wissen Sie die Stärke?
Ja, Ezytimib. Normalerweise benutzen wir dieses Medikament bei der Hyperkolesterminämie um die L-DL-Suppe.
Ja, aber welche Stärke? Welche Dosierung?
Eins.
Zehn.
Ah, sorry.
Zehn Milligramm. Zehn Milligramm. Das ist Ezytimib.
Also wir haben Eutirox, wir haben Rosopastatin, Ezytimib. Und dann hat sie noch etwas erzählt. Sie hat Probleme mit der Galle. Was hat sie denn an der Galle?
Ja, bei ihr wurde vor zwei Jahren ein Gallenstein festgestellt und gleichzeitig eine Gallenblaseentzündung.
Ja, das war vor zwei Jahren. Da kann man sagen, vor zwei Jahren hatte die Patientin eine Cholizystitis und es wurde eine Cholelitiasis festgestellt.
Cholelitiasis.
Cholä oder Cholä?
Ist egal. Manche in Deutschland sagen sie Cholä, manche sagen Cholä. Das ist egal. Ja, das überlasse ich Ihnen.
Aber den Begriff sollten Sie bringen. Nicht Gallenstein sagen, sondern Cholelitiasis.
Ja, Cholelitiasis.
Ja, können Sie auch sagen. Aber wichtig ist, dass Sie den Begriff sagen. Und nicht sagen Gallenstein.
Okay.
Ja? Okay. Gut. Ja, das ist ja der Gegenstand auch der Prüfung. Also die Fachspracheprüfung.
Da sollten Sie möglichst viele medizinische Ausdrücke bringen. Ist die Patientin schon einmal operiert worden?
Wegen der unterstehenden Knochenbruch wurde bei Patientin...
Wiederlegen Sie bitte mal jetzt den Fachausdruck.
Ah, Osteosynthesis durchgeführt.
Nein, das ist die Therapie. Was war die Diagnose?
Die Diagnose H. Fibula... Tibia... Tibiafractur.
Ja, es war eine Unterschenkelfraktur von Tibia und Fibula. Sie hat gesagt, beide Knochen sind warmgebrochen. Beide.
Also die Tibia, das Schienenbein und die Fibula, das Wadenbein.
Und wissen Sie wann das war? Wie alt war die Patientin da?
Was haben Sie gesagt?
Wie alt war die Patientin da als dieser Unfallpatient?
Ah, ja, 30 Jahre alt.
30 Jahre, okay. Also wurde die Patientin sonst schon mal operiert?
Ja, bei der Patientin wurde Hysterektomie durchgeführt.
Ja, wann war das?
Hysterektomie... Entschuldigung, was haben Sie gesagt?
Die Hysterektomie, wann war die?
Ja, vor einem Jahr.
Okay, ich würde bei Operationen möglichst immer chronologisch das sagen.
Weil sonst vergessen Sie die erste Operation der Patientin. Was war die erste Operation in dem Leben der Patientin?
Ja, als sie Kind war, wurde bei ihr mit 10 Jahren Translektomie durchgeführt.
Ja, sagen Sie ruhig Folgendes. Welche Operationen wurde durchgeführt?
Dann sagen Sie möglichst chronologisch die erste im Leben.
Das heißt im Alter von 10 Jahren eine Translektomie.
Im Alter von 30 Jahren eine Osteosynthese des Unterschenkels wegen einer Tibia- und Fibula-Fraktur.
Und vor zwei Jahren eine Hysterektomie. Wissen Sie warum? Was war die Grundlage?
Sie haben von Myome gelitten.
Wegen Uterus Myomatosus. Uterus Myomatosus wäre wahrscheinlich eine durchaus Diagnose.
Und dann wurde eine Hysterektomie durchgeführt.
Gibt es sonstige Risikofaktoren bei der Patientin? Raucht sie?
Sie raucht seit 20 Jahren 10 Zigaretten pro Tag. Das ist viel, aber nicht zu viel.
Ok, aber sie raucht. Als Bemerkung, sie raucht. Und Alkohol?
Ja, ein, zwei Gläser am Wochenende.
Können Sie mir etwas zu Ihrer Familie sagen?
Ihr Vater leidet an alterer Hypertonie.
Er ist 79 Jahre alt und leidet an einer Mithra- oder Trichospidal-Walveinsuffizienz.
Die Herzklappe, die von der linken Herzkammer in die Hauptschlachader geht, hat einen ganz präventiellen Namen.
Ja, die Mithra, die Trichospidal-Walveinsuffizienz. Was haben Sie gesagt?
Die Aortenklappe. Die geht in die Aorta.
Von dem linken Ventricle in die Aorta ist die Aortenklappe.
Die Mithra-Klappe ist vom Vorhof in die linke Herzkammer.
Die Trichospidal-Klappe ist auf der rechten Herzseite.
Das ist die Aortenklappe. Und wenn die Aortenklappe nicht richtig schließt, wie heißt die Diagnose dann?
Aortenklappe.
Insuffizienz.
Das ist die Insuffizienz. Das heißt, die Klappe schließt nicht richtig.
Und während die Klappe zu eng ist und sich nicht richtig öffnet, wie heißt die Diagnose dann?
Aortenklappen-Stenose.
Aortenklappen-Stenose ist die verengte Aortenklappe und die Aortenklappe, die nicht richtig schließt.
Eigentlich müsste sie schließen, sonst gibt es Pendelblut. Das ist die Aortenklappen-Insuffizienz.
Ganz schlimm wird es auch, wenn es ein kombiniertes Aortenklappen-Vitium ist.
Aber Aortenklappen-Insuffizienz ist schon ein wichtiger Fachausdruck.
Weil er kommt doch häufiger vor, auch Aortenklappen-Stenose.
Gut. Das ist der Vater. Und die Mutter?
Ja, die Mutter.
Ihr Mutter ist vor fünf Jahren ein blindes Kind.
Bei der Mutter wurde ein blindes Karsinom festgestellt.
Darmkrebs?
Darmkrebs.
Die Patientin hat gesagt Darmkrebs.
Was ist da die häufigste Diagnose? Welcher Teil des Darmes hat am meisten ein Karsinom?
Wahrscheinlich das Kolon.
Kolonkarzinom.
Also, Appendix ist eher seltener.
Ist ein Zufallsbefund oft, wenn der Appendix auch ein Karsinom hat.
Aber sie hat gesagt, an einem Darmkrebs wurde sie operiert und mit Chemotherapie.
Das war vor fünf Jahren.
Sagen Sie möglichst immer, die 79-jährige Mutter hatte vor fünf Jahren ein Kolonkarzinom mit folgender OP und Chemotherapie.
Und was hat sie noch an Diagnose?
Sie leidet an Diabetes Meletus Typ 2.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, sie hat eine Schwester und eine Gallenblasenentzündung.
Nein, Ekolystitis.
Die Schwester hatte eine Operation.
Gallenkollezistektomie.
Ja, Kollezistektomie hatte die Schwester vor einem Jahr.
Wir wissen nicht die Diagnose genau, was dahinter steckte, aber sie hatte diese Operation.
Was ist denn jetzt Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Aufgrund von anderen Anlassdienstangaben verdacht auf eine Phänomonie und gleichzeitig Handwerkeninfektion.
Es tut ihr rechts hinten rechts Borsal weh.
Sie haben die Patientin bisher nicht untersucht.
Wenn Sie die Patientin auskultieren, perkutieren und vielleicht das Nierenlager abklopfen, dann kann es sein, dass es eher da schmerzhaft ist.
Dass sie da Schmerzen hat.
Es kommt natürlich die Diagnose in Frage rechts basale Pneumonie.
Das kann sein.
Es kann sein eine Pyrlo-Nephritis in der Ecke.
Denken Sie aber auch daran, sie hat ja noch Gallensteine.
Sie hat bekannte Gallensteine.
Auch da könnte die Galle eventuell mit einer Rolle spielen.
Aber ich würde sagen Verdacht auf rechts basale Pneumonie mit der Dispneu.
Das relativ hohe Fieber.
Kommt in Frage aber auch eine Pyrlo-Nephritis.
Das ist sicherlich aufgrund des trüben Urins, des phthiden Urins, der Dysurie.
Die muss man daran denken.
Und natürlich, das werden Sie ja dann mit einbeziehen.
Nach Ihrer körperlichen Untersuchung.
Dass Sie diese Dinge alle untersuchen lassen, die Urin und so weiter.
Gut, ja, es war so ein bisschen von den Diagnosen her so, es war eine Region.
Aber es konnten verschiedene Organsysteme eben betroffen sein.
Mein Wunsch an Sie.
Überlegen Sie in der Vorbereitungszeit für eine Prüfung,
dass Sie möglichst viele Begriffe in Fachsprache übertragen, übersetzen.
Möglichst viel. Ja, so gut das geht.
So gut Sie da Zeit haben.
Wenn Ihnen etwas nicht einfällt, nicht zu lange warten.
Sondern dann gehen Sie zum nächsten Thema.
Aber das ist schon wichtig.
Und ich glaube, da wird auch in der Prüfung durchaus Wert drauf gelegt,
dass Sie eben Fachsprache anwenden und Begriffe kennen.
Und Sie kennen viele Begriffe, aber Sie müssen sie auch hier abrufen.
Das ist immer das Problem.
Und übersetzen.
Ja, das ist das Problem.
Gut, ja, erstmal vielen Dank.
Gute Erholung.
Und ich hoffe, dass dieser Link, den ich jetzt bekommen habe,
dass ich den Link das nächste Mal auch dann einsetzen kann.
Entschuldigung, darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Zwei Fragen.
Eine Frage nach Liptruset.
Die Patiente hat uns gesagt, morgens einnehmen.
Aber Liptruset, ich weiß, dass Antilipidemika im Abend einheben.
Das ist richtig.
Früher wurden die Lipidsenker, die Cholesterinsenker, immer abends eingenommen.
Aber das Rosovastatin und das Atovastatin sind zwei Lipidsenker,
die eine etwas andere chemische Struktur haben.
Und die kann man, das können Sie auch nachlesen im Beipackzettel,
ich habe das zufällig letztens auch gelesen,
die können Sie entweder morgens oder abends nehmen, das ist egal.
Die alten, wie früher Simvastatin zum Beispiel, der Klassiker,
früher war es mir wie Narkoa, das sollte abends eingenommen werden.
Aber die neueren Atovastatin und Rosovastatin können Sie auch morgens einnehmen.
Wir wissen, dass viele Patienten eine bessere Compliance haben,
wenn sie Medikamente morgens einnehmen.
Weil da denken viele mehr dran als abends.
Viele vergessen manchmal abends die abendliche Medikamenteneinnahme.
Atovastatin, Rosovastatin geht auch morgens.
Deswegen kann man das durchaus empfehlen.
Und es ist demip auch.
Es ist demip auch.